congressman jared Polis represents the
second District of Colorado though he's
a typical Democrat in liberal in many
areas he also supports many causes that
matter libertarians like legalizing
marijuana and hemp restraining NSA
surveillance and making space for
virtual currency Bitcoin his background
as a businessman is an Internet commerce
but his background as a child of the
1980s is video games Poulos is not just
a congressman he's a gamer and when
legislation like the Stop Online Privacy
Act also known as SOPA threatened online
gaming culture he turned to his fellow
gamers to put the proposal on ice reason
interviewed him in his DC office about
his positions and his gaming background
okay so give us your gamer cred so
what's your gamer cred
we know about you've been known for
involvement with the game League of
Legends but but how far back does your
gaming interest oh gosh as long as
gaming goes so I'm probably I'm 38 so
I'm really the first generation that
actually was always a gamer so it meant
a different thing in the 80s I mean we
were on very rudimentary products but
some of the you know I played you know
you know kind of wizardry and these kind
of early Apple games you know Nintendo
and so kind of grew up with that and so
adventure games shouldn't real-time
strategy ever since you know Warcraft 2
obviously the civilization series as a
politician then how does your
relationship with video games intersect
with your life as a political figure
well I don't have any of the power here
that I have in survive finding the
entire civilization here we don't have
anything near that level of influence
well it's a fun recreation you know it's
it's I don't really watch much TV so
that's it's a much more interactive
thing I think to do with your spare time
I enjoy it a lot
League of Legends or the
play that a lot you know socially to
just with friends it's a fun way to kind
of kick back and relax do you find
members of Congress coming because you
have a you have a huge background in in
online commerce you were there from
essentially from the beginning well very
early on do you find members of Congress
coming to you for guidance or advice
about tech issues well you know in the
way that it works here is you know
members of Congress who are many most of
them obviously are not experts on tech
when there's an issue like for instance
SOPA and PIPA they rely too much on kind
of what lobbyists tell them and so until
they have to get schooled on it by you
know their their electorate or others
that's going to be kind of the default
is what the incumbent interests are
telling them you know it works and
doesn't work in in that particular case
they said you're against piracy aren't
evil then you support this and then
until they had the you know the full
three or six degrees of understanding
they just thought oh I'm against piracy
therefore I support this let's talk
about this stop online piracy appease
SOPA you actually what got your
attention or the media's attention of
you as a gamer was you actually went to
Riot Games who creates League of Legends
and you appealed to their gamers to
contact their congressmen and their
Senators to fight SOPA so can you tell
us a little bit about what you did with
that sure well it would have been a
major had SOPA PIPA become law at the
time it would have been a major
impediment and negative influence on the
gaming community that arose around not
just League of Legends but a wide
variety of games that use derivative
works and have a lot of lively
conversations and groups that
participate socially as well it wouldn't
really put a crimp on all of those kinds
of communications and and and so it was
really letting people know the public
policy actually affected them it
actually affected them as gamers and the
level of interest was really
unprecedented I mean members of Congress
were deluged with thousands of calls
from constituents on what had previously
been a very arcane issue
yeah and now sopa sopa didn't pass but
there are concerns about it coming back
in some fashion
there always are absolutely you know the
content industry often try
to use and co-opt government to enforce
their own monopolies and we see it
through efforts in the trans-pacific
partnership we see it through efforts to
pass additional laws here in Congress
there always are absolutely you know the
content industry often tries to use and
co-opt government to enforce their own
monopolies and we see it through efforts
in the trans-pacific partnership we see
it through efforts to pass additional
laws here in Congress there was recently
to explain how this affects people a
little bit more and how why gamers
should care about this there was
recently in I believe in December of
some incidents in with YouTube where
gamers videos are being taken down off
of YouTube at the request of game
companies because they included footage
of their video games is this something
you hear about a lot is this something
that we should be concerned about well I
mean I think that when you're playing a
game and I mean different you know it's
not a very enlightened or even a
constructive attitude for a video game
company to play I mean I certainly know
that Riot Games the League of Legends
encourages everybody to post their
footage I mean and they encourage people
to do derivative works they love it when
people do fan art of their characters
and do all sorts of things I mean that
would be a better approach to maximize
return your shareholders for a company
but some are have too heavily influenced
by their IP lawyers rather than their
business people and have a very archaic
view of intellectual property and you
know you have to get into the weeds to
find out whether there was the right to
do that or not but I would certainly
argue it's bad business what would you
like to see done with IP issues
intellectual property issues because
there is the issue of piracy and a lot
of people are concerned about it
so if SOPA wasn't the right thing to do
what should gamers be pushing for well
it's a kind of interesting
I would think discussion within the
libertarian movement too because what
you have and the whole concept of
copyright patent
property protection is you have a strong
government role you're saying the
government will give you a monopoly over
something you invent for a period of
time patent 17-years copyright where we
up to 70 some years and extended you
know so what is that period of time and
what is the enforcement mechanism with
which government guards your what you
have have have created does it
criminally go after people who aren't
even making commercial gain from copying
what you made or does it only go after
people who are trying to steal and sell
your intellectual property what is the
role of government if any there are some
on the more anarchist side and
libertarian movement who would argue
against having government enforced
intellectual property protections there
are some you know and the more kind of
mainstream side or perhaps of the
libertarian movement that would argue we
do need to protect intellectual property
and that is a proper role of government
so I mean there's no right answer I
think the wrong answer is where we are
we really have an intellectual property
system that was designed in the
mechanical era rather than the digital
era it doesn't take into account the
fact that we have instantaneous and
near-infinite replication of works that
can occur in the digital era one of the
things we just recently at reason and
our reason Rupe poll we actually among
our polling questions we determined the
gaming habits of the people we were
pulling and so then we started
cross-referencing that and taking a look
at how gamers looked at other issues
looking for trends or things that
identified that gamers were different
from non-gamers one of the most
interesting things we discovered was
that when you asked a nanny state kind
of question it should people be allowed
to do things like should people be
allowed to smoke marijuana should people
be allowed to get private genetic tests
everything you know all the way up to
you should people be allowed to 3d print
their own guns
gamer's significantly with every single
question we're more likely to say yes
people should be allowed to do things
very much against an estate mentality is
that you know do you think there's
something to that is that something that
comes from being a gamer well first of
all and this people should be able to
know their own genetic code I did a
letter with Thomas Massa to the FDA I
was outraged when they just shut down
23andme for no reason obviously people
have the right to know their own genetic
genetic code I mean there's no there's
no question about that that was
ridiculous overreach yeah I think Amer's
I think the Internet community in
general that tends to be libertarian
oriented that doesn't mean there's not
people across the spectrum but I think
if there's you know bell curve of people
it it shifts a little bit the
libertarian side in terms of those that
are active in internet-based communities
and I think the gamers are just a subset
of kind of you know internet you know in
a heavy Internet users in general so I
mean it would be the same if you're
looking at people that are active on you
know bulletin boards and active in user
groups and you know all those types of
things has always been kind of
libertarian leaning well you know you
don't you know you for you know again
you could be talking to somebody in a
different country and you're really you
know working with them on a one on one
basis I mean there's not really a role
that the nation-state is playing there
it's a very much live-and-let-live type
environment so I think that's kind of
the the culture of the internet so let's
say let's shift over a little bit and
talk about privacy and the NSA so you
are also you're in support of
significant reform of the of the NSA's
collection system
tell us about what your position is
there well these revelations the Snowden
revelations were shocking not just the
American people but to most of us in
Congress certainly although my
colleagues I talked to who had no idea
about the prism program or what or how
was essentially gathering information on
American people who weren't even
suspects of terrorism and it is scary
that there haven't been the right checks
and balances either the congressional
oversight level or from the judicial
branch on the gathering of information
by the NSA so I did run an amendment
with Justin Amash to rein in the NSA to
effectively defund and close down their
their wholesale gathering of information
it came within a few votes of passing
came very close to passing and I think
we're seeing
momentum towards reform doesn't go far
enough yet but at least even the
president is acknowledged and the
program needs to be reformed and I hope
we're moving in the right direction
one last question probably of import to
a lot of gamers and libertarians so what
is this
situation how are things going right now
in Colorado with the marijuana
legalization it's going great
come out and visit please we want your
we want your your your tourism money
come show solidarity even if you don't
buy your smoked marijuana show that you
agree with our laws by coming to our
state and just enjoying our skiing or
hiking and all the other great things we
have to offer it's going well so far
we're dealing with some issues
regulatory issues around banking and
access to banking so they're all cash
businesses now we're trying to get them
approval to have regular banking we
obviously want to change the federal law
I mean none of us want to be in this
predicament where we rely on the
goodwill the president or the Attorney
General
you know what side of the bed they wake
up at a particular day whether they
arrest you know hundreds of thousands of
people in our state or not but at least
it's allowed to occur Colorado and
Washington are experiments that will
learn a lot from and I think other
states will emulate well that concludes
our interview once again this is a Scott
jackford from Reason TV here with who
representative jared polis of Colorado I
want to thank you very much for taking
time out for us thank you Scott